[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis un hacker c'est certainement
l'archétype même que vous aviez aussi
une image totalement fantasmée et
véhiculer à tort par les médias depuis
les années 80 je me pensiez peut-être
proche de ce cliché seul dans ma chambre
tapis dans le noir avec une capuche sur
la tête
à pirater des entreprises du CAC 40 avec
plein d'écran partout qui affichent des
choses totalement incompréhensibles sans
oublier bien sûr le coca et les chips
sinon c'est pas drôle qui parmi vous
dans la salle avait cette image là du
hacker
et bien pourtant aujourd'hui en 2022 il
est bien moins ici et beaucoup plus
facile de gagner de l'argent de manière
totalement malhonnête sur internet que
de vendre de la drogue dans des
quartiers ou dans des cités et ça
certaines mafia et certains groupes
cybercriminels l'ont compris il recrute
des jeunes laisser à eux-mêmes les
mettre dans de bonnes conditions
c'est à dire des locaux de la nourriture
un très bon débit internet et en
contrepartie ces jeunes hacks pour eux
voici le nouveau visage de la
criminalité et c'est un fléau
aujourd'hui en Afrique
la vérité est juste terrifiante le
hacking et accessible aujourd'hui à tout
le monde
plus besoin de grandes compétences après
quelques heures passées sur Internet
quelques tutos ici et là vous pourriez
vous-même acheter un kit pour devenir
cybercriminel
avec ce kit prêt à l'emploi en prenant
quelques entreprises dans votre région
en otage vous pourriez vous faire entre
5 à 10 000 euros par mois
moi-même j'ai parfois je dis bien
parfois était tenté de passer du mauvais
côté de la force
petite dédicace à tous les fans de Star
Wars
cette veille de Noël je suis totalement
à la bourre pour faire mes emplettes de
dernière minute
aussi je n'ai d'autre choix que de me
résigner de les faire sur Internet
après 30 minutes
passées sur ce site Mon panier s'élève à
1200 euros
forcément au moment du paiement mon
esprit un peu tordu ou pas
des scènes une faille sont le vouloir ou
presque
cette femme permettra de régler la
totalité de mon panier non pas à 1200
euros mais à 1 euro
à ce moment là vous imagin vous imaginez
bien l'excitation et à son paroxysme je
me sens bien plus puissant que Kerviel
que Madoff ou même Chuck Norris même si
je vous avoue que de vous à moi il
aurait peut-être hacké le site sans
toucher à son clavier
Noël passe le forêt redescend et je
décide de contacter cette banque en
Europe pour leur faire part de cette
faille monumentale qui pourrait leur
faire perdre des millions d'euros leur
première réaction la méfiance puis la
stupéfaction et ensuite la collaboration
pour corriger ce bug aberrant
elles sont devenues des cibles de choix
pour les cybercriminels chez hacker son
frontières nous aidons ce qui aident
nous aidons ceux qui sont au chevet de
la veuve et de l'orphelin mais qui n'ont
ni les compétences ni l'argent pour se
protéger on leur offre de manière
totalement gratuite la meilleure
expertise qu'il soit et surtout on les
aide à protéger leurs données vos
données dans le cyberespace au-delà
l'ongle sans frontière prône la cyberpée
et surtout porte la voie des pauvres
numériques dans le cyberespace parlons
d'ailleurs de ce que j'appelle les
pauvres numériques aujourd'hui la
fracture numérique gagne tous les jours
un peu plus de terrain l'avènement des
nouvelles technologies et du metavers
n'aideront en rien
si l'on reste spectateur
imaginez un tout petit peu cette femme
qui se fait pirater de 500 euros par un
jeune qui débute à peine le hacking
500 euros se dit-il trois fois rien
juste de quoi se payer peut-être la
dernière console de jeux à la mode
et là cette femme vit avec un homme
violent
il ne supportera absolument pas qu'elle
se soit fait arnaquer
ce jour-là
il la frappe un peu plus fort que
d'habitude
elle décédera sous les coups de ce
monstre
si ce jeune avait été sensibilisé
il aurait su qu'il peut faire
aujourd'hui des études dans le domaine
de la cybersécurité bien encore il peut
gagner sa vie mais surtout il peut aider
des gens et des entreprises en parlant
des entreprises un bon nombre d'entre
elles surtout des TPE font aussi partie
de ces pauvres numériques
elles sont laissées à elle-même ont très
peu de moyens et sans encore les
cybercriminels l'ont très bien compris
ils vont leur demander de petites
rançons entre deux et trois mille euros
et quand ces entreprises là ne peuvent
pas payer ou qu'elles n'ont pas de
sauvegarde
c'est le travail d'une vie qui est perdu
et au-delà une fois encore de vrais
impacts humains
si vous ne deviez retenir qu'une seule
chose de tout ce que j'ai bien pu vous
dire il est urgent de donner une
éducation numérique à nos enfants mieux
encore
une éthique dans le cyberespace
je pense aujourd'hui qu'il est
primordial
de rajouter de l'humanité je dis bien de
l'humanité dans la technologie tout
comme vous éduquer vos enfants
à ne pas rentrer dans une maison lorsque
la porte est ouverte
je pense que l'on doit aussi leur donner
cette éducation là dans le numérique
pour les protéger les sensibiliser mais
surtout qu'il ne se laisse pas tenter
par le cyber-harcèlement ou la
cybercriminalité cette éducation et
l'affaire de tous a commencé par moi par
vous les parents l'école les entreprises
le gouvernement notre responsabilité
je vous invite que dis-je je vous
exhorte
à protéger nos enfants dans le
cyberespace à les éduquer et les
générations à venir pour qu'ils puissent
respecter la propriété virtuelle je vous
remercie pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]